Hello and welcome to this video. In this we will be going over exercise three
where we will be looking at using the stimuli sources.
So we're back in the engine now and I have just come over to the fourth slide
which is exercise three, stimulus sources using the teaching aid.
And you can see what we have here is a setup with another AI
and a number of these coin pickups.
So if I was to simulate you can see that the carriage all wanders around
and can pick them up but not necessarily on purpose.
What we want to change here is we want to create it so that using the perception component
when the AI sees a pickup it will go to the nearest one and pick that up
until they're all picked up.
Okay so let's have a look at our ST stimulus state tree.
Again very simple we have a wanderer about until we see a pickup.
At that point we move to the pickup.
And you'll see in the left hand side here we have the location to move to
and go to pickup balloon.
Again we're using this evaluator setup to get the information from the AI.
Now let's have a look at the AI.
Okay so you can see it's happening here.
Again we are using the on target perception updated
and we are doing our standard check to see which one's using it.
In this case we're using AI site and we are looking at the scene item
and we are checking to see if it is tagged with the tag pickup.
If it is then we are going to what we're going to be doing because there are multiple pickups
and we only really want to go to the one that's closest to us.
We've written a piece of code here but what this will ultimately do
is add the scene item to the array actors to pick up.
And what this is going to do is it's just going to check that it's either not already in the array
because if we see something multiple times we might add it to our array multiple times.
And also that it's not set as our next pickup.
Then we are firing off an event update pickups and if you look at update pickups
basically what it's doing is finding the closest pickup to the actor
and setting that as the next pickup.
We'll also see we have an event that when it's picked up it will fully add the pickup
it will turn it off and it will then update to see if we have another pickup in the cycle.
So all the coding is already done.
To get this to work all we need to do is to jump in to our BP pickup.
And we already have the component overlap which gets rid of it that says it's been picked up.
The only thing that we don't have is any way for this to be registered
within the perception component.
Because we are not a child of the Pawn class, we are a child of the Actor class,
it will not automatically pick us up.
So in order to do this what I'm going to do is come up to the components,
push add and I am looking for the AI perception stimuli source.
When we grab that we do need to choose what source we are registering for.
So in this case I am going to register or cite and the other thing is we want to
also register as a source have that set on
and this will mean that it should be able to pick us up as we're going along.
Okay so I now press compile and save.
And if I jump in I'll run it and see we get a very different behavior.
Everything is just going to go through all the pickups until there is none left.
So that brings us to the end of the stimuli source video.
And this is just we are going to be able to add in a component
that will allow an actor that is not a child of the Pawn class
to register as a source.
I've never used for our site.
Thank you very much.